This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Guys, today we're
doing it old school. I'm not in the studio. I'm in my bedroom. You may even hear some like birds tweeting in the background throughout this episode. But yeah, I had this idea for this episode the other day. I've been really thinking a lot about what gets us stuck in our 20s. how to get out of it. And I thought, I'm just going to, I'm just going to record it. I'm just going to go back to how we used to do episodes and do a little bonus episode for you guys this weekend, in my bedroom, under the covers, into the mic. That is exactly what we're doing. And like I said, today we're talking about stuckness, why it is that we get so stuck in our 20s and kind of the five simple ways I've been thinking about a lot that we can get out of it. There are definitely
I think very few feelings as frustrating as knowing you are not happy with your life, feeling restricted, feeling pessimistic, feeling hopeless, and at the same time, having no clue how to change it. Having no clue like what is even going on, what step in what direction do I take first, it is like claustrophobic is the best word I could use for it. And honestly, I think the longer you wait, um, the more entrenched. in the situation you can become. And it's not to say you won't ever get out of this situation, but I just think the more you begin to internalize the state as permanent, the more you begin to believe that this is just how my life is. And the harder it does become to change,
the more this becomes a permanent part of your belief system. It's very easy to see why we feel this way, why we think that life is never going to be different. And I have to tell you that's false. It's false. Like you have the capacity to change your life. You have the ability to get yourself unstuck. And there are some really simple things that you could do literally today. Tomorrow, if you're a bit busy today, that there's so much easier than you think that are going to break the loop that you are in. I also want to say it is totally normal to feel stuck in your 20s. As hard as this feels on an individual level, and believe me, like I know, It's not a rare thing.
I think during this decade, so much is going on all at once, but also at the same time, so much is not happening that we wish could be happening. And this creates this parallel feeling that, like, everybody else's lives are moving forward. Everybody else is getting their shit together. We should know so much more about what we want to do and where we're going. And yet, you know, it's not happening for us. The only things that we're overwhelmed by are things that aren't, like are things that don't make us happy. And that's really where the stuck feeling comes from. Definitely circumstances
contribute to this. Money, relationships, jobs, cities can make us feel stuck. But a hard truth is that sometimes what really gets us into this rut more than physical barriers or alongside physical barriers is waiting for life to change our circumstances for us. Feeling incapable of making the decisions that we know we need to make. Maybe because we just don't trust ourselves anymore. Maybe because we've been so caught up in like boredom and our routine and how life has been that it feels impossible to disrupt what just feels like the status quo. So that is what a lot of our tips are going to focus on today. Breaking this status quo kind of negativity, same old, same old loop so that you are allowed to expand in a new direction. This is by no means a fully comprehensive list. As I said, I'm just on my mic
in my bedroom. This is just like a fun episode I just had to make. But I do think that these things will really, really help. And I do think that they offer a challenge for you and your mind and your psychology that will prove to really shift things for you in time. Let's start with my first thing. If you are feeling stuck right now, the first thing I need you to do is to map out the problem, map out the ideal future, and map out what you see to be the solutions. There is a very specific way that I do this. I'm a very visual person. And when I feel a roadblock in my life, especially one that's kind of been sitting there for like a couple weeks, a couple months, couple of years, this is the first thing I do.
I get a massive art book or a massive A3 piece of paper. I've even done it on like a poster board. Like, do you know when you were a kid and you had to make a poster on like tadpoles or something or how lemons can turn into energy? I don't know. And you'd get those massive post boards from like the, from the arts and craft store. Get one of those. Divide it into three columns. The first column, what I don't like about my life right now.
A big list, bullet points. You can draw it if you want, but what do you not like about your life right now, specifically? Then you're going to go to the third column. You're going to skip the middle column for now. What do you want your life to be? If all your dreams came true, if all of the roadblocks were removed, in six months, three years, whatever timeline you want to give yourself, what does your dream life feel like, firstly, look like, secondly?
And again, specific, what is the job you're working? What is the feeling you feel in your relationships? What does your friendship circle look like? like, what's the apartment or the house you're living in feel like? What are you doing to nourish yourself? How do you feel about your body? Dream Life column. We have that middle column free for a reason. This is the stuff that you genuinely think would make a difference. So basically, what is going to fix it? What is going to take you from column A to column C, not overnight, but in time? Basically brainstorm. Okay, what in my life?
life actually needs changing and make it visual, make it obvious to you, make it this great big brainstorm of getting all of the doubt and all of the, all of the roadblocks out of your mind and onto the page. The reason I think that this is so valuable is, again, just that so often what gets us stuck is sitting on a problem in our mind, overthinking it, ruminating on it, thinking that that is finding solutions. The moment that you take all of those thoughts and put, put them visually, tangibly in front of you, it's so much becomes more clear. I also think that final column, that dream life column is so important. It's important to create a mental image or to have some kind of focus in your life of
what you would actually strive towards. Feeling stuck is one thing. But often we get obsessed over the stuck feeling and not the outcome feeling. Like where do we actually want to go? So having a clear visual or I guess it's not verbal written idea of what it is is so valuable. I also think that it primes your brain not just to focus on the most drastic sides of the story, right? Not just to focus on how bad your life is right now. Not just to focus on how much do you want to change it and how all the fantasies for your life.
But the middle part. It says the middle part is just as important. What habits, what strategies do we need to implement to get from column, A to column C. And I just think it's like a very simple mind map plan to help you lay out the future, lay out the next few months, just lay out what's actually going wrong in your life and what you want to change. Okay, tip number two to kind of get you out of this stuck state, I need you to do something
hard or create a challenge for yourself that you promise that you will work towards for the next six months. It can be whatever you want. It can be a creative challenge, it can be a physical challenge, it can be a rejection challenge of like, for the next six months, I'm going to get rejected like five times every single week. I know is just as good as a yes for me in building my tolerance for rejection. Just any kind of challenge that's like getting you out of your comfort zone that's giving you something to think about, to work towards, maybe to even obsess over to concentrate energy into
other than just what's going wrong. wrong. Feeling stuck, I think, is sometimes just that, right? Simply not having any forward movement in your life. I think that's genuinely the definition of stuck, no forward movement. So you cannot get out of this stuck state. Like, there is no magic pill. There is no fast forward button. At some point, you're going to have to do hard work and be uncomfortable and make hard decisions. If the first way you do that is something that you voluntarily choose. If the first way you do that is something that you're like, yeah, I'm going to do, like, I'm excited by this challenge. I think that's going to increase your tolerance for future discomfort. That just comes with having a life that is big and a life that
you, a life that you want. There is this amazing paper called, um, the case for friction. And it discusses how the most important thing that challenging ourselves does or setting a six month challenge does is teach our brain to start craving delayed gratification over immediate gratification. And this basically means that in the long term, our motivational systems begin to shift from chasing quick dopamine hits to valuing effort, patience, strategy, consistency, and long-term reward. That is the momentum we need. Nobody gets anywhere in life. Nobody gets out of a stuck state by just doing what they are used to do.
doing, we get out of a stuck state by getting hooked on bigger dreams and more sustained, larger personal reward rather than just like the instantaneous reward of comfort that can actually be quite constrictive, of routine that's actually not serving us. Or even we get stuck because we imagine all the things that we like to do, like in that first exercise, not realizing that fantasizing and thinking about the future in this romantic way, is a way we get dopamine. Like imagining a future that you really want is a dopamine hit in itself. And we can get very obsessed and very hooked on that kind of source
and that kind of input of good feelings from simply fantasizing and imagining. We need to convert that. We need to take those good feelings and turn them into action, turn it into forward movement, turn it into progress. And I thought that sounds like, many like cliche buzzwords, but essentially to rephrase it again, pick a six month challenge, say I'm going to work at this for six months. If at the end of six months, nothing's come of it,
that's fine. The only purpose, the only thing it does is to shock you out of chasing short-term validation or short-term dopamine or short-term reward and shift your mind into seeing the value of chasing long-term reward, things that don't come easily that make your life better regardless. My next tip I think is probably one of the most important and one that I very rarely see people talk about. Stop asking everybody else for advice. If you are stuck right now, everybody else's opinions are not as helpful as you think they are. Because these people either care too much or really don't care at all to give you good advice. Either they care so much about you that they are imagining a life that they want for you
that matches their idea of what success looks like or matches their idea of what security looks like that is never going to make you happy and they're going to start enforcing that on you. I'm like specifically thinking about like parents here. Or you know that people who are just like, yeah, and you should totally do that. You should do that because they're not living your life.
They don't really like they might care about you. They might be your friend. They might even be your partner. But like either they're just going to agree with you or they're just going to. going to be like not genuinely thinking about whether that makes strategic sense for you. You know what you want to do. Like you do know.
Right? You know what your dream is. You know what your next step is. Constantly asking what others think is just a way of avoiding that because that dream feels a little bit too big. And it's just a way of avoiding it because like you know it's going to take hard work. You know it's probably going to mean you lose things. You're going to be exhausted.
but the more you ask other people for their input, the more detached you come from that gut instinct and that intuition that is screaming at you, yelling at you, saying, this needs to change and this is how we're going to do it. Because I think we all have that gut instinct. I just think if you are feeling stuck right now, you actually don't need more input. You need more internal clarity.
And that really only comes from sitting deeply with yourself, reflecting deeply within yourself and then just taking any kind of action whether or not other people approve of it or not. In a very similar vein, getting unstuck means you have to spend less time online. It means you have to get off social media. I cannot express this enough. I deeply, I wish I had more of a vocab. to explain to you how much social media gets you, gets in the way of you figuring out your life. Again, because you are so bombarded by a million different examples of how everybody else is living
their lives. And all those different examples are giving you a different blueprint that is confusing you. Every single day you log in. Who logs in anymore? Every single day that you just open your phone and you scroll. It's like, this is how I change my life. I walk 10,000 steps a day. I did this and this and this. The next person is like, this is how I changed my life. I actually stopped exercising altogether and only focused on this. This is how I changed my life.
I started doing this crazy diet or this crazy routine or this crazy general exercise or I quit my job or I went travel. You could genuinely find in one sitting on TikTok or Instagram 50 different examples of people trying to to convince you or sell you a life strategy that has worked for them that probably will not work for you. How can you figure out, just like that advice point as well, how can you figure out what you want in your life? If your thoughts are constantly being interrupted, intercepted, frazzled by what other people are doing. And I do think that's why we get so stuck is because we want the perfect path. We want to know that everything is going to work out. And so we do seek certainty in other people's lives and yeah in other people's opinions waiting for the moment
when we feel like okay that's the plan that makes sense this is the exact blueprint of things that I need to do and everything will work out for me because this person promised it or because it worked for this person and unfortunately I think it's just the truth of our 20s and the truth of existing um the only certainty we have is hindsight right nothing is going to be promised to you stop searching for like the certified plan for how you're going to fix your life and just move in a single direction. I also think another reason we get stuck and why social media gets us stuck is that it just wastes so many hours of our lives. And that is not a revolutionary statement. I feel like all of us know this. But genuinely, imagine how much you could get done with the time you spend
on social media. If you were to fill those hours with something that you felt connected to, personally. A big strategy for me that I've been doing quite a lot recently is I delete social media the moment I step into my door and I can re-download it when I'm out and about. But in my house, in my home, I really try and limit it or I really try and delete it for extended periods of time. because it's so easy to be sitting around, bored, feeling unmotivated, and to get that low level of reward from scrolling and from engaging in other people's lives. And it just doesn't help you. And there is so much space in those moments that is available for you to actually be doing
something that would be bettering yourself and to actually be doing something, even if it was just planning an adventure or planning a trip or just engaging with your hobbies that would help move the dial when it comes to your life. That actually brings me to tip number five. I kind of just mentioned it, but, and you know what, this should have been number one, because I feel like this is, this really is my favorite. I say this for every single one, but this is a guaranteed way to get you unstuck. Like guaranteed 100% effectiveness rate, go on more adventures.
get out and about in the world, shake up your routine, shake up your life, shake up the status quote of what you do every single day. I feel like when we get stuck, we get into this negative loop, right? This negative loop of everything just going around and around and around, same thing every single day and the adventure, the insertion of adventure is the is the breaker, is the circuit breaker, is the thing that says, oh, we're actually not going to keep doing what we've always been doing today. Great. And your mind grabs onto that and your mind, we know this, loves novelty, loves newness, loves opportunities for new experiences. And it deeply and intensely expands how you see the world. It changes your neural networks. It changes your psychology because when you have
adventures, and I don't mean like of grand hike Machu Picchu, Summit Mount Everest Adventure. I mean like the adventure of going to the next town over and like, I don't know, going on a solo hike by yourself. I mean the adventure of a casual road trip. I mean the adventure of just like doing anything that is fun and that you can write a little bit of a story about and that lets you meet new people, lets you see new things that you usually wouldn't see, that opens doors for you. Mentally, physically, and most importantly, obviously, psychologically. Part of the reason we get stuck again is because we see the world and we believe it's always going to be that way.
we see our lives and we've been so habituated to what they've always been like that we imagine that there is no future where they will not be the same. Giving your brain the opportunity, even the slightest chance to see what else is out there and to see how quickly you could make a decision and be up and going and having a great time is just really powerful. And I think just puts agency back into your hands for changing your life. Well, I think that's all we have time for. Like I said, this was a quick little fun episode for you guys for your weekend.
I hope you enjoyed these tips. I hope they are helpful. Genuinely, that mind map tip, the first one I spoke about, is you could do it today and it will completely shift how you see your problems, at least give you some more clarity. So I would highly, highly suggest it. If you are really in a state of stuckness, a couple of the things that I would recommend. We have this episode called. how to feel like yourself again. I think it was released late last year that really goes into
this in more depth about how to get back to the core parts of your personality and the core parts of yourself that will allow you to trust your instincts more when it comes to making choices. There is also a book that I would recommend called The Anatomy of a Breakthrough by Dr. Adam Alter, who is a dream guest of the podcast, would love to have him on at some stage, but is a powerful book, is a fantastic book, and I think we'll give you a lot more, a lot more of a guide to understanding friction points and to understanding whether it is a mentality or a physical circumstances that is keeping yourself stuck. Because I feel like for this episode, we really only spoke about when it is a mental roadblock, but he talks a lot more about the combination of a
mental and a physical roadblock. So an amazing book, an amazing resource, I will leave a little link in the description below as well as that other episode I spoke about. But yeah, thanks for tuning in, guys. Make sure that you are following. Send this to a friend if you think they may need to hear it. You can also watch full episodes of the Psychology of Your 20s on Netflix, which is pretty cool, not this episode because this is just for my audio listeners, just for you guys.
But other episodes, like there's two a week on Netflix. Yeah, I don't know more to say. I need to get better at self-promotion. I realize that. Oh my God, look at me. Yeah, go watch it. Yeah, go check it out. It does really help the show. And it's a big thing for podcasts and a big thing, obviously, for our podcast as well. You can also follow us on Instagram. You can follow us on Substack. It's all going to be in the description. I feel like you guys are smart. You know where to find it. But until next time, be safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Game.
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of, of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. I'm Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm
Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Traffed podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.